with two new maps released this week and
n DLC on the way next month Killzone
shadow fall is fighting to keep itself
relevant in a soon-to-be post titanfall
world despite a stark drop off and kill
zones online community the hangar into
the cruiser are two excellent new maps
that could read much-needed life into
this satisfying of multiplayer
experience first up the hangar this
multi-tiered open-air killing field
caters to mid and long range fire fights
for the most part but is littered with
enough debris to force you into moments
of close-range panic with kill zones
rotating game modes the tides of battle
shift drastically and well objectives
draw both teams toward hotly contested
control points team deathmatch leads to
more tense long-range exchanges making
use of cover is highly recommended in
either case the hangars a map the
rewards risk while pushing up enough to
climb to the raised platforms on either
side of the map offers a tactical
advantage retaining this position
without serious support is a short-lived
affair too well covered walkways on
either side allow for deep flanks but
push too hard and you'll be met with a
swift end the middle of the map rewards
slow pushes and teamwork especially in
capturing a fold or securing the width
of the map while progressing toward your
enemy or result in a shutout victory
however underneath the entire map is a
winding series of catwalks that turn the
map on his head with deadly corners and
cramped fast-paced combat and of course
a handful the maps objectives are nested
in this death tunnel overall hangar is a
great map that evokes the more tactical
side of shadow fall nicely the cruiser
on the other hand is a narrow corridor
claustrophobia [ __ ] set in a
labyrinthian vs a ship this map caters
to close in mid range combat with an
emphasis on taking cover in advancing
slowly for controlled coordinated pushes
get caught up too deep and kill zones
weighty movement will leave you
lumbering backwards with a face full of
bullets nevertheless the passage is
woven throughout cruiser allow for a lot
of lateral movement which mixes up
objective based modes whereas most Maps
leave you moving either toward or away
from the enemy base cruiser is a mesh of
connected hallways where you never know
if your next turn will lane you face to
face with a firing squad or in
opportunities lab to dominate this map
hug corners use openings to fire off
opportunistic bursts and pay attention
to your surroundings or you might end up
with your head on back
killzone shadow falls multiplayer is
free through tomorrow so feel free to
try before you buy ps4 owners or just
brush up on your skills before titanfall
comes out it's up to you